next item is canal quarter regeneration
zone district energy feasibility study
for December 2018 and that would be
myself as the lead member so the report
is to update members on the findings of
the district energy feasibility study
for canal quarter which is one of the
significant potential developments we
have as part of the core strategy
members will be aware of the impact that
energy consumption particularly for
heating has on our use particularly of
fossil fuels and you'll see a point one
point one that is that accounts for
Serkis 70% of of consumption and the use
of district heat networks in in essence
moving away from individual boilers to a
system that now that bases itself around
provision across a particular
development or a particular number of
houses just seem to offer some potential
opportunities for reducing the carbon
footprint for heating and has been seen
as having a role to play this Authority
in the past has looked at a number of
sites where the district heating network
approach could be feasible and Canal
Quarter is one of those and indeed is
reflected in our own development
requires SPD we have had an initial
study assessing the potential for
district heating which identified the
canal quarter and the subsequent study
that has been commissioned there is the
requirement for a couple further study
to be commissioned to build on the work
of the feasibility study that we
currently have before us and so the the
two recommendations are is that the
feasibility study that we have before us
already is received as part of the
evidence base and will inform
datian of course strategy policies yes
two and three but further than that we
undertake some further work that builds
on that feasibility study for detail so
it is agreed that a commission
consultants to undertake a detailed
project development to develop an
outline business case for delivery of a
heat network in the canal court or in
stratford-upon-avon in other words
getting to the business end of are we
actually going to push forward with
engaging with the developer to to put a
district heat network in on this
particular site I would draw members
attention to paragraph one point eight
where you will note that two-thirds of
the cost of the feasibility study will
be borne by match funding from Bayes and
so therefore the cost is really only
one-third so that is the recommendation
members questions debates views thoughts
Thank You Roger can you just put me
right come on and we will refer to this
as well okay
this made my brain hurt because there is
a lot of information in here
detailed information here which I
suspect would be challenging for most
members of cabinet to read and
appreciate and evaluate so Mike my
question is to what extent can the
cabinet members expect assistance from
officers and or others in arriving at
decisions on this particular project I
think the general answer is that again
as we come to the final end well in
terms of a final decision around this I
would expect that our officers will
provide a detailed briefing for members
of cabinet to help them support their
decision-making process if we decide
that we are going to move forward with
the next piece of work I think that
would then be the check point at which
to because that's how in essence that go
now go decision on so I think noting
that it is a detailed piece of work a
good piece of work but I have far fewer
qualifications than councillor Harvey so
find myself a number of steps behind him
and if if he struggles with it what
chance do I have
but yes that will be the there will be a
detail briefing and it will be in
advance of cabinet to enable members to
assimilate the key decision points
it's a key part of energy in maximizing
the glazing is well made and the
insulation is going to be a big part of
it
members will be aware that we have
already delivered what what is called a
passive house development in wooden one
where the the levels of insulation and
the design of properties is such that
that significantly reduces the energy
use requirement so the daddies part of
the equation and just again for members
of cabinets advice earlier today we've
received consideration on work that is
be a consultation on the future home
standard which again we'll look at using
the building regulations to lever up
standards around energy use energy the
efficiency in
relation over and above that as we move
forward with our own policies and again
we are moving forward with climate
change
supplementary planning document paper
that again will enable us to be looking
at how we leave the other side of the
equation so well made and I think taken
on board I think district heating
networks I are a one of a myriad of
solutions that we will have to deploy as
we move forward there is no sort of one
particular thing so thank you Casa La
Barca um I just want to remind us that
we're not in the 1970s expecting global
cooling anymore but we are expecting a
four degree increase potentially so we
really do need to be thinking about the
cooling system that this has got to be a
reversible system and that it has to
work either passively or neutrally
otherwise you if you over insulate
houses when you've got one that's just
too hot and we're not doing anything
about that and reversing yet then we're
not gonna be doing anybody any favors
we've got to think tiny little bit
further than I think we are at the
moment thank you I think that is a point
that Chancellor Barker you've made
previously and I think certainly I am
looking to officers to take that element
on board that we have to future-proof
these systems so that we don't have the
law of unintended consequences
it's a castle pari far too young to have
our levels thank you for that
[Laughter]
counselor Junaid all members of cabinet
as I understand it got an email from st.
Joseph's and I just wanted to draw
attention to the fact that they had
asked for you know more feasibility
study so I just wanted to note that we
have received that Thank You Julie noted
cancer the Junaid Council a cargo
carrier
Thank You mr. Deputy German to me this
is a complete no-brainer it fulfills our
strategy in terms of the council plan we
need to be seen as innovative we have to
take it to the next stage but like with
councillor barker we've got to have that
flexibility so that we can have dual
both heat and cooling but definitely
gets my full support and thank you to
the officers pulling everything together
Thank You castle Cargill do you have yes
thank you very much indeed interesting
that I look over the budget in the same
way perhaps the councillor Harvey looks
at technical matters I enjoyed this for
many many years and we we are playing
catch-up to a certain scent on this we
must must must progress low-carbon
schemes and I pick up the point of
castle Barca saying it must be flexible
as well but you must bring these up as
opposed to for example gas powered power
stations just fire power stations ok
ridiculous in this day and age and the
game going against what we were saying
before so I think it's incumbent upon us
to make sure that this
is a good scheme if we can make it work
let's do it
so I'm thanks you can't I've got cash
flow while the Huggins and then
counselor kettle a combined scheme sort
of protections we can put in place for
them as to maintenance charge it's
because we're seeing issues of that
arising in other matters across new
developments really and I think that we
do need to be mindful of that given
given this kind of must be factored in
to almost if we need to protect the
residents with some comfort from
escalating charges really thank you what
are the weight of this scheme could work
is that we is a district council
actually their management agents for
that for their district heating scheme
so one would hope that I will get the
protection to the customers can select
kettle just following up councillor
Paris comments ready this is this is a
great way to move forward but now it's
just as well that this won't be the only
opportunity we have to roll out a
district heating plan and that in moving
forward we do we don't Taylor it's so
closely to canal quarter it becomes less
helpful to other areas and that we try
and make sure that the lessons come out
this rolled out in other schemes big or
small across the district observation
I'm sure we should be looking for
flexibility roll these systems across
the district so in the absence of any
further discussion recommendations I've
got an update to recommendations
so I'll read you the additional that the
whole of the new recommendation so the
first recommendation is that the
district energy feasibility study is
received as part of the evidence base to
inform the implementation of core
strategies policies cs2 and cs3 the
second recommendation is that it is
agreed to Commission consultants to
undertake detailed project development
work to develop an outline business case
the delivery of a heat network in the
canal quarter in stratford-upon-avon and
in so doing to allocate a sum of 50,000
paths from the council's general fund
reserves to fund the business case
members will be aware that there is a
two-thirds input from central government
so may I have members thoughts on the
two recommendations that agreed thank
you very much move to the next item item
six on page 29 of your agenda papers
which is the West Midlands combined
authority reason or recent regional
design charters and the purpose of this
item members is to endorse WMC ice
regional design charter to help inform
planning decisions and policy
developments most notably when we come
to a review of the core strategy its
purpose is to leave her up the quality
of design across and placemaking across
the West Midlands and the supporting
regions these designs are meant existing
local planning authority documents not
to supersede or to replace them members
the recommendation is that the West
Midlands combined authorities regional
design charter attached at appendix
won't be endorsed to inform planning
decisions and policy development most
notably the review the core strategy I
would advise that members in our policy
team have reviewed and had input through
the officer working group act of um CA
to the to the strategy
the document doesn't actually cuts
across anything we're already doing more
than with this document anybody have any
comments questions thank you then is
that we all agreed is the management
contract the member is required to
satisfy this requirement the methodology
sultans experience of procuring alleged
management contracts for councils and
the proposals before this afternoon
reflects their advice the report has
also been informed by a stakeholder
workshop session carried out in June
this year which was attended by myself
cancer Jackson counsel Harvey and
councillor Barker to ensure that the
proposals matched our aspirations for
the service going forward the three
recommendations are set out at the start
of the report and Tony and I are happy
to take any questions thank you I'm
speaking here as chairman of the ovn
scrutiny committee which looked at it
this at their meeting on the 6th of
November and at that meeting there was a
very positive response to the inclusion
of the environmental and energy
management as part of the evaluation
which was a recommendation that came
through from the climate change task and
finish group and I'm glad that that has
come through to this stage and but the
point was made that obviously with that
being as part of the evaluation we will
need to see a report ordered back
backwards to make sure that that we are
seeing that there is an outcome that is
positive a cost benefit to the council
so if we can as part of the evaluation I
think it's in here that they should do a
footprint when they when the when the
procurement is done and then there
should be a report back there was a
couple of other comments that were made
however as well
being reviewing performance at the
accent of the contract the the footprint
is X yeah and then measuring it at you
know twelve months five years down the
line for example is that why you get
almost quite sure whether you were
talking about reviewing the first point
make sure that we we know that it an
investment put in into any particular
energy system or any technology we learn
the lessons basically from it we know
what works and what doesn't work but
there was a few other comments that were
made from the overview and scrutiny
committee that I said I would bring
forward which were included looking at
the the the usage a customer usage of
the Alicia's making sure that priority
groups people with maybe young people or
various other groups were properly
considered during the the tender and
during the operation of the leisure
center that the affordability is
considered and as well as this reporting
an audit on the invalid and energy
evaluation so those as did say that I
would bring those forward and I think
there are of the comments in the room
in the last contract in the sort of
final knockings we were down to sit to
contractors bidding against each other
so we did have to take through here one
of the risks that we have in procuring
this contract is attracting a wide range
of features and we've designed thank you
it's a good opportunity an exciting
opportunity for us to also look at the
wider health benefits of a ledger
contract which you can actually roll out
to our communities so it's not just and
I'm not saying it's a simplistic as
there but the everyone active was
getting for example the contract can be
widened to include far more health and
well-being which we hope one day we'll
be brought into the family but on the
serious note that does show how certain
elements outreach elements can be
brought into this particular contract
for the wider benefits of the cuing
society it's an exciting time for us to
be out but these contracts that make
sure that element is incorporated in it
Thank You counselor car girl counselor
kettle just to build on what you know to
say
I think we must recognize the need to
make this result is available to all not
just those with a very high media
profile but those who are perhaps less
just to make sure that it is that to use
the facilities everybody in the district
couldn't feel comfortable going to use
them we may be driven by legislation
which but to make sure that I think most
keen to emphasize with the new contract
procurement is that we are looking for
diversity and we are looking for a
little bit if you like out of the box
and that's why we're making this as fair
as possible so that perhaps some of the
smaller providers can come forward with
confidence that they're carefully and
I'm proud for Stratford that we've
actually got the bid is laid out for you
here and how we're doing that because it
will encourage initiative and it will
encourage exciting opportunities I
believe that we're going to make these 4
million pounds available as a capital
sum that they can then use to expand the
services that we've got they don't have
to use it but it does actually make that
sum of monies available for them teasers
alone that they can then really set to
and give us a major service that we can
be very very proud of unlocking forward
into the future and that's councillor
kettle said you know we want to be able
to engage with with all members of
society and make
services available to them we've already
may made sure that the younger people
can come into use gym the gym facilities
for as long as possible during the day
that's not as restrictive as it was you
know we should be proud proud of that
we've listened to what people wanted and
we've been able to react to that but I
am confident that we are giving the
scope here for some fantastic
initiatives to be led and to see what
that brings and I think that we live in
exciting times and we actually do look
at the bids that are being brought
forward and there is really missioned
within the bidding process that that
they will be recognized for thinking out
of the box as it were mr. perks do you
want to add anything thank you no I
think keeps summed up most of the things
here we've tried to design a procurement
here that will attract the most sort of
economically viable and diverse measure
offer that we can afford really we've
we've done what we can in the
procurement design by making suspending
available thing in the active community
strategy to pick up a lot of the topics
that people have raised with us the
energy issues so hopefully we'll see
some interesting bits thank you I think
with that I think we've we've given that
a good airing so the recommendations are
number one that the proposed procurement
process detailed in section two below is
approved recommendation two that the
proposed evaluation criteria for the
contract award as set out in section
three below are approved and that's the
head of technical and Community Services
brackets or any other job title is
appropriate and closed brackets in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for community be authorized to advertise
and award the contract in accordance
with the approved budgets and evaluation
criteria are we all agreed thank you
very much indeed
so we now move to our next item which is
under the operations portfolio that's
page 45 on your agenda papers the
stratford-upon-avon district castle
buildings cleaning service contracts
lead member can slash Anton
I just wondered what sort of assurances
can be put into the tender process to
ensure that we do achieve the quality
because obviously we're here in this
situation because of whether specific
monitoring can be put in place or a
break clause or something that if we
find that it is not a standard that we
can actually do something about it
within the term evaluation waiting quite
a high wage from supervision higher than
we've taken at previously because we
felt success in these contracts depends
in terms of quality for management on
site incumbent contractor who's chosen
to manage this contract remotely and
it's we've increased that waiting
we've also clear what's expected the
contractor and we've simplified the
default mechanism so in the event that
we're not getting the service that we
require it's much much clearer that we
can take action against the contractor
so those three mechanisms in place
Kassel JUnit just again that the
evaluation process now requires
environmental standards as part of the
procurement which is welcomed look again
could we have reports back perhaps as to
what that exactly means maybe after
twelve months thank you I'm sure
officers will note the the request from
overview and scrutiny for ongoing
performance management information I
imagine for all of our contracts as they
and their impacts on climate change so I
think we probably think officers mr.
perks there is an error in the
evaluation criteria waiting if you look
at the cost element the maximum points
available should reach 40 having scaled
the heights of being appointed deputy
chief executives can we just inquire
about your mathematical educational
attainment grades it's taken us read
about performance review performance of
all contracts and how they impact on
climate change and I think officers will
just have that I imagine written into
their thought processes from here on in
it is just about learning the lessons
all the time and making sure that we
know and understand and that we don't we
always go forward rather than slipping
absolutely learning learning from every
situation is always a good thing mr.
perks recommendations are that the
proposed procurement process detailed in
sections who is endorsed and the
proposed evaluation criteria for
determining the suitability of
contractors to tender shown in appendix
2 is approved the second recommendation
is that the
head of technical and Community Services
bracket inserts of the job title as
appropriate close bracket in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for operations is authorized to
advertise and award the contracts in
accordance with the approved budget and
evaluation criteria are we all agreed
thank you kindly now move to item number
nine which again is under the operations
portfolio so I call on counselor Jensen
talk to the item review of off street
car parking charges and parking permits
that starts page 53 of your agenda
papers
members I am aware that councillor Rolf
has indicated prior to the meeting that
she would like to speak to this item and
I have agreed that she may do so I'm not
clear whether mr. Baca no wants to join
with her will make any representation
himself for mr. Baca I am happy that if
you wish to make some representations
you should do so should we there's a
maximum of five minutes for four
speakers just five minutes between and
then thank you very much whenever you're
ready
Business Improvement District so I have
talked to many many older people and I
think they would consider the region to
increase and and they might some people
have suggested perhaps you also might
consider that you give them incentive to
people that have an electric vehicle or
a hybrid vehicle I think that's a great
initiative so thank you very much and
I'll hand over to Joe thank you very
much councillor son from allowing me
turn to speak and my views on this I
shared them with miss Burt's mr.
Buckland and councillor Shenton and and
Pemberton from my perspective this feels
like an incomplete reports the data is
presented in Appendix 1 isn't really
there in terms of comparison so actually
you can't really see the workings where
you can get to is councillor Jensen has
acknowledged it so essentially this is a
financial measure I would have liked to
have seen more in terms of the data the
comparisons the potential impacts which
are not within the report and then
potentially some levels of investment
that my the district may be willing to
to put in I've shared what I gave to
councillors gemstone Pemberton with the
board the business the business members
on my board are alarmed at the level of
increases being proposed particularly
when we talk about the average dwell
time being three pounds and that would
place
Stratford as more expensive than
lamington and Rahl priced car park
obviously they have a vested interest in
holding shoppers there is only two
pounds for three hours
we wouldn't obviously would not suck
because that would be a step down but it
places Stratford on a level with
Solihull and Worcester
turns the car parking charges for those
time bans as part the consultation I'd
like to do more work and actually
provide you with more information to see
this but there is significant concern
amongst the business community
particularly in the way that the retail
is currently struggling I've know I've
full understanding and the reasons
behind looking at car parking I may well
have written similar reports in the past
myself as an officer in a previous life
but we do believe it's likely to result
in a drop-off in usage in the town
center particularly and potentially from
locals so I'm glad you're going to
consult I'd miss some mr. Berg's pointed
that out to me that there will be a
consultation
it just wasn't clear and as I said I
feel the report is not as comprehensive
as
thank you I just want to kind of talk as
chairman of the climate change task and
finish group on this one because I was
disappointed actually because the
increase in charges including the stop
in their IEP permit was labeled as an
environmental response in the press
release not as you now stated as a
revenue raiser we've been very
particular in our approach on the task
and finish group because we recognized
that not only is climate change very
complex it's multifaceted it frequently
makes choices between competing
priorities but it's more important that
we take people with us we have to have
stakeholder engagement you have to
consultation we have to be able to
demonstrate benefits and Co benefits for
thee and later on in the year there is
the s and s is looking at a transport
strategy we had intended to input our
response to that transport strategy
because you need a whole well
thought-out approach that was so that
we've got the overall transport strategy
the infrastructure the alternatives the
availability of Park & Ride the
availability of partnered buses
availability of a whole raft of things
that you've got an overall strategy that
knits together and that you can and sell
and my my disappointment was that if the
ad hoc approach is taken we risk
undermining confidence and won't achieve
the change needed and I want to see
climate change properly address and it
has to be done in a proper cohesive way
not by taking one point at a time we
will be putting our report together at
the end of this year from the task and
finish group and I hope our input to the
transport strategy as well as some of
the other strategies from the for the
council will be taken seriously thank
you thank you I'm on this Chancellor
Perry I'll make some observations
to take concessionary parking permits
have them reviewed whether and I welcome
that fact but if I'm right in thinking
consistory parking permits are basically
24/7 says someone with a concessionary
parking permit can actually park their
vehicle for a complete unlimited time
whether it may be sensible
if we are continuing them to perhaps
introduce a limit of say a maximum of
three hours which would be I would have
thought for that category of age group
and as I'm someone who's going to be 65
next year you know a three are visiting
to Stratford would accommodate the
theater would accommodate shopping would
accommodate luncheon I just wonder
whether a limiting on a specific hours
might be a sensible approach and
reasonable
I just felt it important to just
recognize the fact that it has been some
time since this counsel raised car
parking fees and I think that we should
applaud ourselves for that really
because that that is significant we
haven't it is I'd also like to endorse
what counsel try it was talking about
with regard to the limited parking now
lots of parking is at a premium do have
this system it's a very simple system
that people don't don't what time they
arrived in the car pal you got like a
cardboard dial that you use and actually
giving out these dials to people wanting
to park is actually a really good
motivational thing faster getting
shoppers to come into town and also it
if you do limit it to three hours it has
a galvanizing effects that people go and
do what I need to do so thank you I
think that's a very wise proposal Casa
La Barca the question I have to ask is
who these permits I've heard from ships
turn one lobbying event my email box is
totally empty of such stuff the only I
had was that it was a bit of a shame
that it might I said will it stop you
coming and parking shopping in Stratford
and parking no she didn't really think
so now but if the parking is I would
have assumed it was to draw people into
Stratford that we allow that concession
if it's a if it's actually being used by
people who are in Stratford already is
that actually the purpose to which it
should be put seriously thank you I
think I would just make some
observations I think I take on board
councillor do needs desire as we all
have a desire to integrate this stuff
and pull to a solution in one the
reality is we're not going to be able to
do that in every in every case
the we've heard early earlier today
we've discussed the climate change
supplementary planning document and you
could reasonably put an argument
together that that should be deferred
until an entire course strategy review
however but it's a rational decision and
case was made for moving forward on that
item beforehand so I think he's it is
reasonable to move on certain items
there Arthur there is both a financial
and a and an impact on climate change we
have to start to modify people's
behaviors and cost of parking is going
to be something that factors into that I
would observe that perhaps anybody who
is so price sensitive that an annual
permit costing 10 pounds losing that or
seeing an increase in that he's going to
affect their shopping habits and they're
going to go to lemming s'en they're so
price sensitive that I think
bricks-and-mortar retails had it because
they'll just shop online the other thing
I would also say so we've got to start
making it's this whole concept that
people will drive around the town
looking for parking spaces looking for
the cheapest parking space but that
whole point of most of them using
vehicles but that are petrol or diesel
has to become socially unacceptable
I'm sorry you know if we are truly
serious about this then I'm afraid when
we park out of our vehicles it is going
to cost and we do have to have an eye to
the impact on the economy but I'm sorry
that the concept that people will drive
around the town or drive to lemming
tynin increase their view of usage to
save themselves 50 P or a parent here
and there I'm afraid that you can't base
policy on that I was absolutely
delighted to hear counselor off talking
about emissions based charging because I
think that is somewhere where we can
make a difference the challenge is going
to be however there are a lot of people
who come into this town a shot Drive
three and a half two and SUVs
which in an urban environment and the
town is an urban environment are largely
inappropriate so we are going to have to
then address the point of those vehicles
going to be more expensive to
because if you give a discount for it
Eevee's you have to offset it for the
larger vehicles and and personally I
think that will be something that will
drive changes in behavior but it will
come as a shock to people so I suspect
this is that you know the you know the
first taste of how we have to make
difficult decisions we and a point one
point six is absolutely key we the chief
exec and I and the leader had a meeting
with the county talking about
integrating car parking how we get more
use of the park-and-ride how we get the
park-and-ride open you know in a way and
having a charging structure in a way
that gets people to use it what we can
do about rationalizing car park and so
we can have that conversation we are
left in a bit of a piecemeal so it is
not perfect there is a desire to have
the conversation with the county and
other operators of car parks in the town
the tank council operator car park we
will all have to come together and we
all have to have the same we can't just
have the district council charging non
emissions for vehicles we'll all have to
do it so this is quite difficult but I
would say that yeah we we do have to
start down this road so we have an
amended recommendation and people happy
with the amended recommendation does it
does anybody need it reading out
together then are we happy
so are we happy with Castle a sentence
mean amended recommendation that the
introduction of the charges be approved
subject to consultation in line with the
off street parking orders and they're
similarly charges for the concessionary
Park King permits for their over 65s be
reviewed as part of that proposal
we all agreed Thank You councillor
Harvey the finance and assets portfolio
capital budget monitoring pages 59
this is to give them some reassurance
that we are looking after this x16 money
and using it appropriately
first of all management team receives
regular reports to review progress and
make sure that such 106 have been
utilized secondly members received this
report every two months which includes a
section and you can see updates of the
schemes and finally with the express
purpose of ensuring that's quick summary
of how we review and monitor the
progress of the section 106 funding
questions for Castle Harvey the
questions oh I do apologize
castor kettle just looking at page 67
the very first line is probably the
biggest figure on the whole of that page
money not yet received to come in this
year cleaning timed with the completion
of the section 106 106 money so probably
that's something for mr. weeks to take
offline and perhaps provide an update
for all members of the cabinet and copy
to yourself members cabinet the
recommendation is that the position on
capital expenditure income for the
periods 1 to 6 of 20 19 20 years
received any issues identified for
further consideration by further reports
the cabinet support by the portfolio
holder I think we just picked up one
item which I think can be dealt with by
circulation to to all members of cabinet
observers and the Chairman but we
content with that thank you very much
so we then moved to our next item quite
some 11 revenue budget monitoring page
75 of you report papers again that's
councillor Harvey
there seems to be somewhat at odds
between what government is saying about
universal credit and housing benefits
and our experience on the ground quite
it's a consistent that's been going on
for a long long time what what can't
what representations are we making to
government or not do you think they're
actually listening mr. Platts can you
provide some clarity from behind the leg
no come and join us
in terms of representations we're
continually speaking to the IR RV who
were the professional body and also
credit its roll out the impacts has been
shared more widely through the LGA thank
you mr. Platts any I think the feedback
is that but the progress on the rollout
of the Universal Credit remains slow
file under diplomatic answer okay so the
recommendation members is that the
actual net variance has a period six and
the estimated revenue acts over twenty
nineteen twenty years received and any
additions identify further consideration
we receive both further report to
cabinet or by the portfolio order are we
agreed thank you very much we now move
to Part C issues arising from overview
and scrutiny committee and what we have
here are the interim recommendations
from the climate emergency task and
finish group members you will have a
separate paper here obviously ordinarily
counselor Richards would present this
but Kathleen Junaid would you just like
to perhaps talk us to the highlights
thank you
yeah there are four there were four
recommendations on the Tuscan finish
group that went through the overview and
scrutiny committee and they were you
know scrutiny committee
where was satisfied with those
recommendations the recommendations are
number one that there should be a stand
in panel with some recommendation as us
to work streams for that standing panel
to consider and work their way through
one of the one particular ones that I
want to highlight is about housing
because that poorly insulated houses
homes waste energy lead to high
emissions and high energy bills for
residents they we have the evidence that
we have is that as few as 40% of the
homes in the district are well insulated
so with that's something that we would
like to do more of there is also other
recommendations for them to work through
as like a working work stream for the
panel is to look at things like tree
planting land whether or not there is an
audit of land across the district that
could be used for suitable sites for
biodiversity biodiversity net gain tree
planting education opportunities and
then whether or not there is any
feasibility in facilitating bulk-buy
schemes for residents to access solar
panels again this is all has to be
worked through an energy policy is one
that we would liked the Tuscan finish
would like a standing panel to work
their way through about the how we
encourage more renewable energy
production because the overall
production in this district does lag
behind the best of similar local
authorities and we do want this count
district to be a leader and then about
communications it is essential that we
always take people with us and that
means how we communicate with people is
essential so those were the support of
the that the standing panel would work
their way through these are our
recommendations for that standing panel
the second recommendation was that if
the council is to achieve is ambition
for the district to become carbon
neutral by 2030 there does need to be a
dedicated officer resource and we have
said that that they exactly how that's
delivered is up to the
to the cabinet but we create could be
co-funded with other councils or it
could be funded within the council or it
could be an officer that could be that
could be used within the council but we
do think that there is a resource needed
to be able to really work through
there's a lot of work involved in doing
a proper climate change not only
strategy but management plan and a
carbon action plan to follow as well a
lot of work recommendation 3 is about
community leadership which is a key role
for the council and that is not only
training and development but also
leading by example so we'd like to see
members trained and to understand
unpolished councils to understand
exactly what climate change will entail
and what kind of work will be managed
we're also asking that the cash
management working group should look at
the current investment portfolio and
whether it underpins environmental
sustainability and whether or not the
council should move towards paperless
committee meetings I've got plenty of
paper here admittedly
but whether it's better technology could
could help and the recommendation for is
that again it's part of this taking
people with us making sure that
everybody understands what we do and
that we understand what other people's
concerns are as well and that this
should be an annual climate forum that
will involve businesses organizations
and other public sector bodies it bodies
that would act as an any encouragement
for these bodies that they're taking it
their own independent action but how
they could work in partnership and how
they could learn from each other there's
some extremely good examples happening
across the district of community is
really helping each other in a myriad of
ways and it would be lovely to be able
to share some of those those lessons
that they've learned and how they can
communicate with each other
I think Thank You councillor Junaid I've
just got some questions but I will go
last I think
Perry was first Thank You deputy leader
um canceled unit I'm just sort of
focusing in on your point on housing and
insulation is the committee aware that
legislative changes to the lettings
industry lettings
sector that landlords can't let a
property unless it reaches an EPC rating
of an e however if they then get quotes
for insulation costs thus exceed three
and a half thousand they can then
register their property on the EPC
exemption register which lasts for five
years I just wondered whether the
committee were when you're looking at
insulation homes whether there would be
any merit in assessing how many
properties actually fall below an EPC
ear ating and have subsequently been
registered on the exemption register yes
that would be extreme for this standing
panel to have a look at they we have to
look at the installation the the energy
efficiency rates of council buildings we
have to look at the energy efficiency
rates of private homes we have to look
at the energy efficiency rates of
Housing Association homes as long if we
can control that of course but that's
that's see how we can work in
partnership but also privately rented
homes the it is the case that in this
district this and more it dis tricked
you'll be surprised to learn are the two
areas of the whole county that have the
highest fuel poverty rates which does
seem rather odd but it is because some
of its because of heritage house you
know listed housings and older housings
but some of it is also because maybe the
message is not getting through about
what people can do for themselves
and I know that when the Green Deal
pilots were looking at rented landlords
and rented accommodation not in this
district thank goodness but they were in
other districts we did come across you
know some extreme difficulties with
there so it doesn't need to be done it's
it's a question for the panel to look at
not only what the EPC is is what the
requirements are what the legislation is
but also what we as a council could do
either by giving advice or for other
ways but it is for the standing panel to
come out with the final results thank
you I was negative just a critical
friend shall we say just want some
comments and I'm sure council unicum can
answer some of these all consider them
in item or recommendation about a
standing panel obviously we have to look
at costs has this been talking about a
detailed feasibility study so have we
got costs included in that one and you
also mention about the research carry
right the Friends of the Earth do we
look at other organizations as well so
we can have more balanced view backs so
that's on that particular one on the
community hub part you say the setting
up of a dedicated community space not
quite sure what that means but surely
isn't that something that the local
councils do or couldn't do I'm just
trying to stop duplication I don't want
to duplicate and add costs to any
anything at all so if we can if we have
something there let us look at using
going over the page interesting on tree
planting and council bark and I will
discuss this one before I think as in
district we do quite well because of
course we do have the heart of England
forest as well and they that actually
does give us our green credit
credentials quite well however I do
agree that we should be looking at the
farm or at planting trees and such like
suddenly we don't have an awful lot of
land available for doing that but the
county might do so perhaps a we could be
looking in there right now this is one
that you know only too well on solar PV
and renewable energy and I appreciate
this is just a very short report says
giving residents access to solar panels
on both my schemes well obviously it's
not just simply buying equipment that
goes with it to actually feed back into
the grid or alternatively what I'm
looking at is actually storage battery
storage so I can actually run my house
for example of an evening or
alternatively taking cheaper power and
this is one of the interesting points
about using gas-powered power stations
they run cheaper at night so you can use
your energy at night to actually charge
about yourself and then use that during
the day so you keep maximizing it's just
something some of the options I think
that should be presented to to residents
as well I gotta say something um
personal thing I don't like wind farms
communications totally we do need to get
that out and I think an independent the
way of doing that is absolutely
essential okay
regards to the an educational program
but unfortunately our we have a very
very busy training program as you know
for members very busy
relatively alternate training dates
might have to be considered so it's just
run things that it's just simply fitting
it into the system more than happy to
look at it and we'll talk it so with
David or be as well on that one now I
totally agree we do need to get some
education out there i t you mentioned up
tapeless yes that is one of our drivers
is to try and get the the council as
paperless as as possible it never will
be completely paperless such as a a myth
but yes we're trying to work on that and
and we're trying to roll something out
in the new year okay just just on that a
lot of these are for a standing panel to
look at in more details because we we've
only got up till Christmas really to to
do our report there to go through all
these is wood is a lot of work beyond
what we've got the resource to do
however things like for example on the
research there are a number of
instruments there's one called scatter
which is a base commissioned piece of
software which can look at footprints of
the carbon footprint for that for the
district offered and for the over they
the council itself it needs to be worked
through the Tyndale Center has also got
an instrument and but it needs it needs
time to work through those that that
research to establish the actual car
before we've done research I think the
council has done research on carbon foot
but it needs to be updated so these are
suggestions for a standing panel and and
I completely agree with you on on the
hubs that if anything that is happening
we you know gather within our family of
what we're trying to do
and you know whatever's happening within
hasta for example with the repair cafe
or anything else like that these are in
good examples that we need to make sure
and and solar PV and etc it must be part
of an overall energy policy for the
district
these were suggestions for the Banat
stunning panel to come through a theme
but we've got to have an overall a panel
overall policy and then the final the
final report will come from the task and
finish group in December but that's not
the end of the work it cannot be the end
of the work it to do a proper climate
change action plan and carbon management
plan will take an awful lot of work
beyond what this Tuscan finish
Robert weeks would be able to tell you
an awful lot more and he has already
told and told the AVI and scrutiny
committee a lot about what the planning
could do in making sure that there is a
biodiversity there is no loss to
biodiversity and trees but also the
there is a government guidance that we
should have biodiversity net gain so we
should be actually every time there is a
planning application we should be trying
to gain not just replace trees and and
other things and one of the ideas is
that if there is none that has no other
you know news if there is a way in which
we can if this land for example that is
needed for flood prevention flood
resilience it's areas of land that can't
be used for other things then why not
try and see if we can pull it pull it
together work with others like the heart
of England forests working with wild
light Trust work with other
organizations to see if we can make a
real green you know real difference in
what they call living landscapes which
is not just little bits patches of green
little patches of biodiversity in trees
but you know where did they connect it
together across a district and where we
can really gain from this initiative for
the benefit of everybody in the district
Thank You councillor Jane it's just sort
of I think what what we need to
understand is is what the ask is and my
interpretation of the ask and then we
can just try and see potatoes well the
first thing is that I think long since
been on record saying that actually
Tuscan finish is the wrong approach this
is a long ongoing thing so I'm
absolutely delighted
front and center is the concept that
overview and scrutiny will have as part
of its Standing Orders if you will or
standing approach climate change and
addressing the climate change emergency
as I see it under recommendation 1
you've listed a number of areas which
are to some degree your work program as
far as I can see and I think where I if
I'm correct where I think this is going
is that you're looking to set up a panel
if you will or a team within OSC or an
approach that says climate change runs
through everything but then you want to
look at a number of different areas and
I think that that work stream if you
will becomes owned by OSC and under each
of these headings you will put together
a work stream and my advice is this is a
work stream that runs a minimum of three
years probably more like five because
this isn't this is definitely not a
twelve-months don't start thinking in
terms of you municipal year think about
the long term and you know you know when
I get to five years in between kind of
long term aspirations and dovetailing
where some of this stuff might fit in
with other work that's being done
potentially around the core strategy
potentially around government guidance
and updates he's probably the way to go
and then as you come to each piece of
work then you're looking for the
business case for the Rev you know for
the additional costs that will
inevitably come with with these things
now that is probably where I think that
we're where you are with recommendation
one with recommendation two I think what
I'd really be looking for I think what
cabinet would be looking for is for you
guys to is to in conjunction with
relevant officers you've got just in
support in the OSC but with the section
one five one officer in there and the
and the chief executive to start if that
is a recommendation to start to build a
business
case if we're gonna do this we're gonna
there's going to be a budget attached to
it and we need to sort of feed all of
that in if we're going to consider that
again you know things around so the
member development working group do we
do something now as a an initial or do
we wait until you've got some of you
work rounded up and we you know so
timing and liaising with with Casper
Cargill and David oddly think is
important again I think looking at how
having some discussions with with
section one five one officer about how
the cash management working group and
with the portfolio holder thing to
understand a bit better whether a final
again with recommendation for I think
really need you to think it again to
bring you know put some more flesh on
the balance of that and again come up
with a budget I think there there isn't
push back on these things I think what
it is it's now taking it to the next to
the next point at which we can start to
make rational day-to-day decisions about
how we are going to spend the money that
we can put towards this and how we're
going to prioritize this so you work
stream I think you own you own that work
and you decide what the what the
priority is but be but be minded to
think about what canceller Shenton and
the officers are doing around the waist
contract what john kerr further myself
doing around core strategy then that's
my thought process around that and
members of the cabinet and mr. Grafton I
think you wanted to hop in there just
along your lines I'm reading into
recommendation one it's what you're
really looking for when you use the word
adopt is looking for a steer from
cabinet as to whether those work streams
recommendation two and I can see the
words to investigate but there again
you've had the pushback from the deputy
leader about costings on that
three in terms of member development
group again the question is about timing
of that cash management working group
you put should consider and I suppose
the question back to you would be are
you asking the cabinet to communicate
with working group to consider whether
direct communication with working papers
as well and again the climate whether
you want we needed guidance to make sure
that we could proceed that we could get
into their budget process that we could
get into the seeking advice I am on the
cash management group anyway but I did
need to be get approval that I can speak
with a climate change voice there so
it's it's just it's making sure that we
have the ability to move this on CASL
Huggins that you have something there
I think to be fair you have my your
point is well made and you have made the
point to me around how the climate
changed us with this group I think we
are getting to the business end of some
some recommendations and I think
actually there is this is the point
where you need to be far more involved
in all of this I think what we've tried
to do is to send a message to the
climate change task and finish group
that the seriousness of the matter is we
now need to move into the operational
bit and hopefully we try to give you a
steer yeah can I just say I would
welcome you we the when it was set up
there was to be a cabinet member on and
so far he's been councillor pemberton
that has been there but I'm happy to
have any cabinet member that feels that
they've got a particular input to and
what we're doing to do with your welcome
always welcome I think we're probably
now we've we're past the point now where
we've demonstrated that you know the
cabinet he's you know gets this and I
think we're moving into the operation on
the delivery face so I think absolutely
rigidity you happy that that gives you a
sort of Styria yeah I think yeah you
workstreams you start to own you know
and that's I would say long-term and
then bringing forward you guys doing the
research on some on some business cases
for the various different things and
then we can start to make some sensible
decisions
yes I think what we're looking at is
that the the overall recommendations
from the overview and scrutiny Committee
on climate mergency are supported
subject to further clarifications
business cases and prioritizations in
other words yep
go get go I get on and some of this work
I think take take it as read that at the
conclusion of your task and finish group
you've got an ongoing piece so some of
these trips into that ongoing piece
so don't approach it on the basis if you
produce this report and then we've got I
think we're into that transitional
period does that make sense it does mean
we needed we needed to make sure that we
got the guidance we needed to make sure
that you were aware of what we were
doing early enough to be able to think
of it through the budget process etc
rather than just waiting until our
December report comes when it probably
would be too late to be doing some of
the things that we're suggesting thank
you noted thank you very much is that
all agreed members have come upon it
thank you
sorry move to Part D cabinet committees
under leadership of government
governance the housing Investment panel
to receive the minutes on pages 87 and
88 of the housing Investment panel
members the key considerations from that
is that a bid was presented by spring
Housing Association lining a bit of 300
thousand pounds to support a housing
transition service and the fitting out
of a building
potentially to be known as the thread
winter center is that correct
so I understand it's to be the Fred
winter Center bed was presented and and
was supported with the funding released
to be released
and obviously that was the discussant
decision of the investment panel subject
to any calling bio SC and the the group
then briefly considered the meetings of
OSCE task and finish group around how we
might achieve a reduction in in
evictions however we really didn't get
into the the business end of that
because of considering so members just
received a noted in this district so
then move to the next item on the agenda
on block items there are no on block
items and then moved to a Part F which
is other matters item 14 urgent business
I'm not advised of any urgent business I
now move to item 15 which is exclusion
of the public and the following reports
and appendices contain exempt
information as defined by the following
paragraph part 1 schedule 12a at the
Local Government Act 1972 para 5
information and respects of which it
claims a legal professional privilege
could be maintained in Proceedings par 3
relating to the financial or business
affairs for any particular person
including the authority therefore move
that pursuant to section 100 a bracket
for closed bracket of the Local
Government Act 1972 bracket as amended
close bracket the public be excluded
from the remaining business of the
meeting in view of the fact that the
nature of proceedings will be such that
if the public were present there would
likely be disclosure to them of exempt
information of paragraphs 3 & 5 of part
1 of schedule 12a to the said Act
bracket as amended close bracket are we
agreed thank you